être un pas réitéré hier ses accusations
contre la chine
selon le président américain le coville
19 proviendrait d'un laboratoire chinois
haoran l oms elle estime que le corps à
la virus et je cite d'origine naturelle
pour françois durpaire historien
spécialiste des états unis le locataire
de la maison blanche cible pékin pour
s'attirer les faveurs de son électorat
c'est un nationaliste de d'un trône donc
il réagi à la crise du coc vie de 19
selon mme son adn politique il ne peut
pas lui reprocher c'est son adn
politique il dit très clairement à son
électorat
la menace c'est la chine vous vous
souvenez de son slogan mais cavalcade
great game fair que l'amérique soit
grande à nouveau grande à nouveau contre
qui contre la france contre l'espagne
contre l'italie via non contre la
puissance qui effectivement rivalisent
avec les états unis sera dans quelques
années à n'en pas douter la première
puissance mondiale la chine donc dans
son électorat très clairement
et bien il y a ce rappel de sa campagne
électorale de 2016 la chine était déjà
l'adversaire des américains des emplois
américains
et là évidemment et bien il ya une
gradation à mesure que l'on avance vers
la présidence tout simplement la
campagne électorale